From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. And to explain what we're doing on today's show, let's just begin with a little story.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。为了解释我们今天节目要做什么，让我们先从一个小故事开始。
My parents said that we should have a dog. But didn't want to have a dog that was going to be all doggy.
我父母说我们应该养条狗。但他们不想养那种“狗味儿”太重的狗。
This is Alex Blumberg, one of the producers of our show.
这是我们节目的制作人之一，亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
This is the irony. They did a lot of research to find the dog that would be the least hassle.
讽刺的是，他们做了大量的研究，想找一只最省心的狗。
And wait, what were the specific hassles that they were trying to avoid?
等等，他们具体想避免哪些麻烦？
The were trying to avoid loud, slobbery, sheddy.
他们想避免吵闹、流口水、掉毛。
OK.
好的。
And they did avoid those sorts of hassles. But what they didn't know is that they were trading it in for a whole other set of hassles that were much larger and much worse than they ever could have imagined. What they got is they settled on a Basenji.
他们确实避免了这些麻烦。但他们不知道的是，他们换来的是另一套更大、更糟糕、超乎想象的麻烦。他们最终选定了一只巴仙吉犬。
Basenji?
巴仙吉犬？
Yeah.
对。
I've never even heard of that breed.
我甚至从没听说过这个品种。
Yeah. They're sort of a rare breed of African hound. They're barkless. Our dog would howl occasionally.
是的。这是一种罕见的非洲猎犬。它们不会吠叫。我们的狗偶尔会嚎叫。
They can't bark, but they can howl?
它们不会吠，但会嚎？
Yeah, they can't bark, but they can howl.
对，它们不会吠，但会嚎。
That's like saying somebody, they can't talk, but they can scream. They're a mute, except for the ability to yell at you.
这就像是说某人不会说话，但会尖叫。除了会冲你大喊大叫之外，它是个哑巴。
Exactly.
没错。
Trumpkin-- they named him Trumpkin-- howled all the time. And the howling was a lot louder and weirder than barking. And Basenjis, Alex says, they're just a strange breed.
特朗普金——他们给它取名特朗普金——一直在嚎叫。那种嚎叫比吠叫更响、更怪。亚历克斯说，巴仙吉犬就是一种很奇怪的品种。
It's a weird line, and it hasn't been domesticated as much as other dogs. And so they're really, really wild-looking and feeling. Most dogs, they interact with you, and they wag their tails. And they come up and the pant. He wasn't like that at all.
这种狗很怪，不像其他狗那样被驯化得那么好。所以它们看起来和感觉上都非常狂野。大多数狗会和你互动，摇尾巴。它们会跑过来气喘吁吁的。它完全不是那样。
He was wily and disobedient. When they left him inside the house, he would rip apart the sofa cushions and the pillows, and destroy the furniture. When they put him out in the backyard, he would tunnel out in hours. He'd pick fights with cars. He was fast enough to catch squirrels, so there were always squirrel carcasses all over the block.
它狡猾且不听话。把他在屋里时，他会撕烂沙发垫和枕头，破坏家具。把他放在后院，他几个小时就能挖洞跑掉。他会挑衅汽车。他跑得足够快，能抓住松鼠，所以街区里到处都是松鼠尸体。
He'd overturn trash cans. He'd disappear for days. The day Alex's family moved to Cincinnati, Trumpkin ran across the street and ate the bunnies, real bunnies, that the little girl across the street had just been given for Easter.
他会掀翻垃圾桶。他会消失好几天。亚历克斯全家搬到辛辛那提那天，特朗普金冲过马路，吃掉了邻居家小女孩刚收到的复活节兔子，真的兔子。
And it was impossible to get him back in once he was out. Eventually, he would just come back in. You'd just let him roam his path of destruction through the neighborhood until he finally--
而且一旦他跑出去，就不可能把他抓回来。最后，他总会自己回来。你只能任由他在邻里间进行他的“破坏之旅”，直到他最终——
His killing spree.
他的杀戮狂欢。
--until he finally tired himself out. And then he would eventually come back at night, exhausted.
——直到他最终筋疲力尽。晚上他才会精疲力竭地回来。
Covered in blood.
浑身是血。
Covered in blood, or beat up, or bitten through. That was the other thing. He didn't just pick on smaller animals. There was all these other neighborhood dogs, and he was constantly-- I think especially the Irish setter, I don't remember his name. But he was constantly pushing that Irish setter's buttons.
浑身是血，或者被打得鼻青脸肿，或者被咬伤。还有一件事。他不只是欺负小动物。街坊四邻还有其他狗，他一直在——我觉得尤其是那只爱尔兰雪达犬，我不记得名字了。但他一直在惹那只雪达犬。
The Irish setter was much bigger than him. And they were constantly getting in fights. He was constantly getting in fights that he lost.
那只爱尔兰雪达犬比他大得多。他们总是打架。他总是打输。
But on the bright side, to get back to the family's original desires for a dog, he didn't shed. He didn't slobber.
不过从好的一面看，回到最初他们想养狗的目的，他不掉毛。他也不流口水。
It had been six months or a year of him destroying all our furniture and tipping over garbage cans and enraging our neighbors and running away and getting in fights. And so my parents decided that they'd had enough. So they gave him away. And they explained it to us that he just was not a city dog. And they gave him to this couple who owned a farm in Indiana. And he was going to be much happier than he would be cooped up in our house.
半年还是大半年过去了，他毁了我们所有的家具，掀翻垃圾桶，激怒邻居，到处乱跑，打架斗殴。所以我父母决定受够了。于是他们把他送人了。他们向我们解释说，他不适合在城市生活。他们把他送给了印第安纳州一个开农场的人家。他会在那里过得比被关在我们家里更开心。
So Indiana from Cincinnati, how far is that?
那么从辛辛那提到印第安纳，有多远？
Just over the border in Indiana. So he was maybe 40 miles away, 35, something like that. But of course, I was heartbroken. And I would come home from school every day. And I'd be just so depressed that he wasn't there. And I remember crying myself to sleep.
就在印第安纳州边境那边。所以大概离这儿40英里，35英里之类的吧。但我当然伤心欲绝。每天放学回家，我都很沮丧，因为他不在那里。我记得我是哭着睡着的。
It was horrible. We were all very sad.
太可怕了。我们都很难过。
Alex's mom and dad say that shortly after the couple from Indiana took the dog, something started to happen.
亚历克斯的父母说，那对印第安纳州的夫妇带走狗后不久，事情就开始发生变化了。
I don't know how long it was, but we began getting some phone calls, I would say they were two or three, from people saying that they thought they had our dog, but he got away.
不知道过了多久，我们开始接到一些电话，我记得有两三个，有人说他们以为捡到了我们的狗，但狗跑了。
Or we had your dog in our backyard, and he escaped. Or we had your dog tied to a rope, and he chewed through it. He had a tag, of course, with our name on it, and our number. And every time the call came, it would be a little bit closer to us.
或者说，我们在后院发现了你的狗，但他逃走了。或者我们用绳子拴着你的狗，但他咬断绳子跑了。当然，他脖子上的名牌上有我们的名字和电话。每次接到电话，都会发现他离我们越来越近。
And then my mother was driving home from work on her usual route. She was going down this highway called Columbia Parkway, which is four lanes.
然后有一天我母亲下班回家，走她平时的路线。她开在哥伦比亚大道这条四车道的高速公路上。
And I see, trotting along the road, Trumpkin.
我看到特朗普金正沿着路小跑。
And he was trotting along in the direction of our house from the direction of Indiana. And it was rush hour. Cars are whizzing by. And before she even gets to him, he recognizes the sound of our Datsun station wagon.
他正沿着从印第安纳方向回我们家的路跑。当时正值高峰期。车流呼啸而过。她还没来得及靠近他，他就认出了我们那辆达特桑旅行车的引擎声。
Come on.
得了吧。
And, my mother told me this story, spun his head around and then started chasing the car. And she was like, the jig is up. He's coming back. So I might as well make it easy for him.
我妈给我讲过这个故事，他转过头，开始追车。她心想，瞒不住了。他要回来了。所以我最好让他上车轻松点。
I pulled over quickly and opened the door, and he jumped in and sat on my lap and yodeled. That's what Basenji's do when they're extremely happy.
我迅速靠边停车，打开车门，他跳了进来，坐在我腿上嚎叫。这就是巴仙吉犬极度高兴时的样子。
Oh, the word that Alex uses for that is "howl."
哦，亚历克斯用这个词来形容“嚎叫”。
Yeah, howl or yodeled.
对，嚎叫或者说吟唱。
So he shows up back, and you take a breath and you say, OK, I guess I've got to deal with this. Were you happy, or were you resigned, or were you a little of each?
所以他回来了，你喘了口气说，好吧，我猜我得处理这事儿了。你是高兴，还是认命，还是两者都有？
I think I was more resigned than anything else.
我觉得更多的是认命。
Yeah. You weren't happy.
是的。你并不高兴。
No.
不。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Trumpkin had always been so aloof, Alex says, and then he came all that way to be back with them.
亚历克斯说，特朗普金一直很冷漠，可他竟然跑了那么远只为回到他们身边。
It was quite an amazing gesture. It was sort of touching. And I think that's sort of like, it did made us think differently, it made me think differently about him, a little bit, I think even then. That I was like, wow, he really-- we felt very loved by him and very special in his eyes. And it was hard not to feel the same way after that.
这真是一个了不起的举动。这让人有点感动。我想这确实改变了我们，让我对他有了些不同的看法，即使在当时也是如此。我当时想，哇，他真的……我们感到被他深深地爱着，在他眼中非常特别。在那之后，很难不产生同样的感觉。
You know that song, "The Cat Came Back," that old camp song?
你记得那首老营火歌《猫又回来了》吗？
That's it.
就是那个。
That's your dog, man.
那就是你的狗，伙计。
That's the dog, right. Trumpkin had a million lives.
没错，就是那条狗。特朗普金有九条命。
He definitely felt indestructible. I saw him. I saw his head get run over by a car.
他绝对看起来不可摧毁。我亲眼见过。我亲眼看着他的头被车压过去。
Come on.
得了吧。
I did. It ran over his nose and front foot. And he popped up, and he came back, and he was all dazed. I saw it happen. And that happened over and over and over. Literally, I think he got hit five time by a car.
我真的见过。车从他的鼻子和前脚上压了过去。他跳了起来，又跑了回来，虽然有点发懵。我亲眼所见。这种情况发生了一次又一次。我敢说他至少被车撞过五次。
After a while of all of this, did it seem like he had a supernatural power?
经历了这些之后，他看起来像是有超自然力量吗？
Oh, yeah, definitely. It definitely did. Towards the end of his life, they took him to the vet for something or another, and they did an x-ray. And on the x-ray, there was all these glowing points all over his body where angry neighbors had shot him with a BB pellet. He was glowing with BB pellets.
哦，是的，绝对有。确实如此。在他生命临近结束时，他们带他去看兽医，拍了张X光片。片子上显示他全身布满了发光的点，那是愤怒的邻居用气枪子弹打的。他全身都是气枪弹。
It's a supernatural quality, the whole thing that's like that song, "The Cat Came Back." You know the song I'm talking about? In each verse, the cat is drowned, or he's shot, or he's electrocuted or given away. And then in the chorus, the cat comes back the very next day, no matter how impossible that would be.
这确实是一种超自然特质，整个过程就像那首歌《猫又回来了》。你知道我在说什么歌吧？歌词里每段那只猫都被淹死、枪杀、电击或者送走。但到了副歌，不管多么不可思议，那只猫第二天又回来了。
They took him down to Cape Canaveral, put him into place. They shot him in a satellite up into outer space. They thought that the cat was beyond human reach, but then they got a phone call from Miami Beach.
他们把他带到卡纳维拉尔角，把他放好。他们把他装进卫星发射到外太空。他们以为猫已经超出了人类的范围，结果又接到了迈阿密海滩的电话。
Then the cat came back, the very next day, blah blah blah, you know. OK, the song actually dates to 1893, written by a man named Harry Miller. And people have probably added hundreds of grisly verses of the song over the years. It is possibly, and I know that it's hard to generalize with this kind of thing, but it is possibly the most gruesome kids' song ever.
然后那只猫第二天又回来了，巴拉巴拉，你知道的。好吧，这首歌实际上可以追溯到1893年，由哈里·米勒创作。多年来人们可能给它加了几百段残酷的歌词。这可能是有史以来最恐怖的儿歌——我知道很难概括这类东西，但这真的是最恐怖的。
They sneaked him in a shop with the butcher not around. They dropped him in the hopper where all the meat is ground. The cat screamed and screamed with a blood-curdling shriek. The burgers from that store tasted furry for a week.
他们趁屠夫不在偷偷溜进店里。他们把他扔进绞肉机。猫发出了撕心裂肺的尖叫。那家店的汉堡吃起来有一周的毛味。
Sweet dreams, kids. The original lyrics include a train that's going west and an old-time riverboat. One of the great things about this song is that every generation adds new, contemporary ways for that cat to perish.
做个好梦，孩子们。原版歌词里有去西部的火车和老式内河船。这首歌最棒的地方在于，每一代人都会为猫的死亡增加新的现代方式。
The atom bomb fell just the other day. The H-bomb fell in the very same way. Russia went, England went, then the USA. The human race was finished, without a chance to pray. The cat came back the very next day. The cat came back. We thought he was a goner, but the cat came back. It just couldn't stay away.
原子弹就在前几天落下。氢弹也以同样的方式落下。俄国没了，英国没了，美国也没了。人类种族灭绝，连祈祷的机会都没有。那只猫第二天又回来了。那只猫又回来了。我们以为他死定了，但猫又回来了。他就是离不开。
I've got to say, it's easy to understand why this song has lasted over a century-- catchy melody, and a story that anybody can understand, even a little kid. It is actually the simplest plot in the world, when you think about it. You want to get rid of something and it returns, mysteriously, and against all odds.
我得说，很容易理解为什么这首歌能传唱一个多世纪——朗朗上口的旋律，加上任何人都听得懂的故事，甚至是小孩子。当你仔细想想，这是世界上最简单的情节。你想要摆脱某样东西，但它却神秘地、违背常理地回来了。
And for this week's radio show, we thought, there have got to be other stories like this, true stories, real life stories, not about cats. And so, today, proudly, we bring you an hour of stories just like that, real life cat came back stories, of things in our lives that just won't go away. As I said, it's This American Life. Our show today in four acts. Act One, Promise Keeper Cat. Act Two, Political Cat. Act Three, Baby Cat. Act Four, Refugee Cat. Stay with us.
对于这周的节目，我们想，一定还有其他这样的故事，真实的故事，发生在现实生活中的，不是关于猫的。所以今天，我们很自豪地为您带来一小时这样的故事，现实生活中“猫又回来了”的故事，关于我们生命中那些怎么也摆脱不掉的事物。正如我所说，这是《美国生活》。我们今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，守信的猫。第二幕，政治猫。第三幕，婴儿猫。第四幕，难民猫。请继续收听。
Act One, Promise Keeper Cat. It's actually the story of a pledge that somebody made that he wondered if it had gone away. He wanted it to go away. And, well, you'll hear what happens. Dan Savage tells the story.
第一幕，守信的猫。这实际上是一个关于某人做出的承诺的故事，他曾想过那个承诺是否已经随风而去。他希望它消失。好吧，你会听到发生了什么。丹·萨维奇讲述这个故事。
In 1996, 16 years into the AIDS crisis, I made a promise to my boyfriend, or my ex-boyfriend, late at night, while he ate a pint of ice cream, lying on his deathbed. I broke that promise. And with each passing year, I feel worse about what I did, or didn't do.
1996年，艾滋病危机爆发16年后，我对我的男友，或者说前男友，在一个深夜，他躺在临终病床上吃着一品脱冰淇淋时，许下了一个承诺。我违背了那个承诺。每过一年，我对自己的所作所为，或者未做之事，就感到越发内疚。
It happened like this. We got serious, fast-- too fast-- moving in with each other a few weeks after we met. Five months later, we decided we should go get tested for HIV, or I decided we should go get tested for HIV. It was the fall of 1995. My test came back negative. Joseph's did not.
事情是这样的。我们很快就认真起来——太快了——认识几周后就搬到了一起。五个月后，我们决定去接受艾滋病病毒检测，或者说我决定我们应该去。那是1995年的秋天。我的检测结果是阴性。约瑟夫的不是。
I was holding his hand when the counselor at the testing center told him he had HIV, something he had long suspected but was never sure he wanted to know. 29 and beautiful, he was tall, with broad shoulders, long, blond hair, and huge, blue eyes. He shared his fears with me. He didn't want people to think of him as ill. He didn't want to be pitied. He didn't want to lose his looks. He didn't want to die alone. Four months later, I dumped him.
检测中心的咨询师告诉他感染了艾滋病毒时，我正握着他的手。这是他长期怀疑但从不想确认的事情。他29岁，英俊潇洒，身材高大，肩膀宽阔，留着金色长发，有着蓝色的大眼睛。他向我倾诉他的恐惧。他不想让人认为他生病了。他不想被人怜悯。他不想失去容貌。他不想孤独地死去。四个月后，我甩了他。
It wasn't the disease. There were other issues. Sometimes, when another guy talked to me on the street, in a restaurant, he would fly into a rage. I couldn't deal with his jealousy, and so I left him. Or maybe that's too convenient. Maybe it was his HIV, or his smoking, which always drove me crazy, or the jealousy, or all of it.
不是因为疾病。还有其他问题。有时，当另一个人在大街上、餐馆里跟我说话时，他会勃然大怒。我无法应付他的嫉妒，所以我离开了他。或者也许这只是个方便的借口。也许是因为他的艾滋病，或者他的吸烟习惯——这总是让我抓狂，或者是因为嫉妒，或者是这一切的总和。
The night we broke up, he wasn't sick. He had HIV, but not AIDS. But a week after we moved out of the apartment we shared, one of Joseph's lymph nodes became so swollen and painful, he couldn't avoid going to the doctor.
我们分手的那晚，他还没有病发。他携带病毒，但没有患艾滋病。但我们搬出合租公寓的一周后，约瑟夫的一个淋巴结肿胀且疼痛，他不得不去看医生。
The biopsy confirmed that Joseph had lymphoma, an AIDS-related cancer. He also had thrush and Kaposi's sarcoma. The doctors call these things opportunistic infections. We gay men called them the beginning of the end.
活检证实约瑟夫患有淋巴瘤，这是一种与艾滋病相关的癌症。他还患有鹅口疮和卡波西氏肉瘤。医生称这些为机会性感染。我们同性恋群体称之为末日的开始。
I cried with him in the living room of his new apartment the night he told me. Joseph had to start chemo immediately. His doctor put his chances for survival at 30%. And even if he survived the cancer, the Kaposi's sarcoma would likely kill him, or some other opportunistic infection. Joseph joked, sort of, that it was too bad his lymph nodes didn't swell up a week earlier. "You couldn't have dumped me if I was dying," he said. "You got out just in time."
那天晚上他在新公寓告诉我时，我和他一起哭了。约瑟夫必须立即开始化疗。医生认为他的生存几率是30%。即使他能熬过癌症，卡波西氏肉瘤也可能会杀死他，或者其他什么机会性感染。约瑟夫开玩笑说，虽然不太好笑，要是他的淋巴结早一周肿起来就好了。“如果你知道我要死，你就不能甩我了，”他说，“你走得真是时候。”
After leaving Joseph's apartment that night, I thought to myself, "Here we go." At that point, in 1996, the AIDS caregiver role was well established. I'd read Paul Monette's On Borrowed Time and Last Watch of the Night. I'd seen Longtime Companion and Parting Glances. I knew my part. As Joseph slowly came undone, I would divide caretaking chores with Joseph's best friend and fellow ex-boyfriend, Marcus. I would accompany Joseph to the hospital, yell at doctors and nurses, pick up his meds, bring him groceries. At the end, I would lift him off his bed, help him dress, wipe [BLEEP] off his legs, carry him to the shower and the toilet and the couch. And when the time to die came, I would hold his hand and tell him to let go. Which brings me to the promise.
那天晚上离开约瑟夫的公寓后，我对自己说，“开始了。”那时是1996年，艾滋病护理员的角色已经非常明确。我读过保罗·莫内特的《借来的时光》和《深夜守望》。我看过《长期伴侣》和《离别之瞥》。我知道我该扮演的角色。随着约瑟夫身体逐渐崩溃，我将与约瑟夫最好的朋友兼共同前任马库斯分担护理琐事。我将陪约瑟夫去医院，对医生和护士大吼大叫，帮他取药，给他带杂货。在最后，我将把他从床上抱起，帮他穿衣，擦掉他腿上的[消音]，把他抱到淋浴间、马桶和沙发上。当死亡时刻来临时，我会握着他的手，告诉他放手吧。这就引出了那个承诺。
Late at night, I was sitting with Joseph in his room at Swedish Hospital in Seattle. He was undergoing another round of chemo for the cancer, feeling nauseous. He had lost a dangerous amount of weight, so I brought him some ice cream. His long, thick hair had begun to fall out, so he shaved it all off, because he couldn't bear to watch it come out in clumps. He was very skinny. I told him he looked good bald, which wasn't a lie. Joseph was one of those guys who looked good in anything, even his deathbed.
深夜，我坐在西雅图瑞典医院约瑟夫的病房里。他正在接受又一轮化疗，感到恶心。他瘦得惊人，所以我给他带了一些冰淇淋。他浓密的头发开始脱落，于是他把头发全剃光了，因为他无法忍受看着头发一把一把地掉下来。他非常瘦。我告诉他光头看起来不错，这不是谎话。约瑟夫是那种无论穿什么都好看的人，即使是在临终病床上。
I sat for a long time in the chair next to his hospital bed. "I will always be here for you," I said. "You can count on me. I'm not going anywhere."
我坐在他病床边的椅子上，坐了很久。“我会永远陪着你，”我说，“你可以依靠我。我哪儿也不去。”
But then everything about AIDS changed in the United States. The year Joseph got sick, a new class of AIDS drugs suddenly became available, protease inhibitors. Taken in certain combinations, dubbed cocktails by gay men, naturally, these drugs returned many very sick men to seemingly full health. Basically, the 16-year-old script that Joseph and I were reading from the night I made my promise had just been ripped up, only we didn't know it.
但后来美国关于艾滋病的一切都改变了。约瑟夫生病那年，一种新的艾滋病药物——蛋白酶抑制剂突然上市了。这些药物以特定的组合服用，自然地被同性恋群体称为“鸡尾酒疗法”。这些药物让许多病重的男人恢复了看起来完全健康的身体。本质上，约瑟夫和我那个晚上在承诺时朗读的那个16年前的剧本刚被撕毁了，只是我们当时不知道。
When I told Joseph that I would always be there for him, neither of us expected him to be here much longer. By promising to be there always, I was committing to six months, a year, tops. Then came the drugs.
当我告诉约瑟夫我会永远陪着他时，我们都没指望他能活多久。承诺永远相伴，我以为最多也就是半年到一年。然后药物出现了。
And the cocktails worked a miracle on Joseph. The swelling in his lymph nodes went down. His hair began to grow back. He put on weight. He got out of the hospital. What we thought was a six-month death sentence stretched into a year, then two.
鸡尾酒疗法在约瑟夫身上创造了奇迹。他淋巴结的肿胀消退了。头发开始重新长出来。他体重增加了。他出院了。我们以为的半年死刑，延长到了一年，然后是两年。
I would drop by Joseph's work, which was near my office. He seemed to be doing fine. My visits started to come further and further apart, and further.
我会顺路去约瑟夫工作的地方，离我办公室很近。他看起来做得很好。我的探访间隔越来越长，越来越长。
Then one day, I realized I hadn't seen Joseph, the only guy I had ever promised to be there for always, in more than a year. I was gone, new boyfriend, an adopted child, other commitments. And over the years, I found myself wondering about that promise, wondering about the kind of person I was to turn my back on a promise like that, but wondering mostly if Joseph was angry with me.
然后有一天，我意识到我已经超过一年没见过约瑟夫了，那个我唯一承诺过要“永远陪着”的人。我离开了，有了新男友，领养了一个孩子，还有了其他承诺。多年来，我发现自己一直在想那个承诺，想自己是个什么样的人，竟会对这样的承诺背信弃义，但更多是在想约瑟夫是否在生我的气。
I had released myself from the solemn commitment I made without even having the decency to discuss it with him. To this day, I wonder, really, what you owe someone who is about to die, someone who has, in a sense, promised you that they're going to die, and then comes back. So I called Joseph up so we could speak, finally, about all of this.
我未经商量，甚至没表现出起码的礼貌去谈一谈，就单方面解除了自己许下的庄严承诺。直到今天，我还在想，你到底欠一个快死的人什么？欠一个在某种意义上已经承诺你要死，却又回来了的人什么？所以我给约瑟夫打了电话，希望能最终谈谈这一切。
OK, so when you got sick, when you got lymphoma, when you were in the hospital, when you were getting chemo, I promised you that I would be there for you always, and that you could count on me. And then you lived.
好吧，当你生病时，当你患淋巴瘤时，当你住院接受化疗时，我承诺过我会永远陪着你，你可以依靠我。然后你活下来了。
Was that disappointing?
那会让你失望吗？
No, it wasn't disappointing. It was what we all wanted. It was what I wanted.
不，并没有失望。那是我们都想要的。那也是我想要的。
It's what I wanted, too.
那也是我想要的。
Despite the fact that I haven't seen Joseph much, at all, really, over the last 10 years, we've maintained a sort of tenuous connection. Joseph cuts my boyfriend's hair, and our son's. After an appointment, my boyfriend always lets me know that Joseph looks fine, which is code for "Joseph's not dying." And a half a dozen times in the last decade, I've run into Joseph on the street. These meetings have always felt a little awkward. I know Joseph is doing fine. He's been with the same guy for seven years. But still, seeing him, I always felt somehow incriminated, guilty, caught out.
尽管过去10年我几乎没怎么见过约瑟夫，但我们维持着某种微弱的联系。约瑟夫给我男友和我儿子理发。预约之后，我男友总会告诉我约瑟夫看起来不错，那是“约瑟夫没死”的暗号。在过去十年里，我在街上偶遇过约瑟夫半打次。这些会面总是感觉有点尴尬。我知道约瑟夫过得很好。他和同一个人在一起七年了。但即使这样，见到他，我总是感到某种被指控、有罪，被抓现行的感觉。
What's always felt awkward for me about the promise, and we've never discussed the promise since it was made, and it sort of faded away, was that it was really premised on this idea that I will be there for you always, asterisk. Always means six months to a year. And here we are 12 years later, 11 years later. Was there ever any sense that I had failed you by drifting away, that I had broken my promise?
关于这个承诺，一直让我感到尴尬的是——我们自做出承诺后从未讨论过，它就这样渐渐淡忘了——它实际上基于这样一个想法：我会永远陪着你，但有个星号。永远意味着六个月到一年。可现在我们在这里，12年后，11年后。你有没有觉得我因为渐行渐远而让你失望了，或者我违背了诺言？
As far as your promise to me, even though we lost contact for quite a long time, and didn't really maintain, except for "Hi," on the street, I never personally let that promise go.
关于你对我的承诺，尽管我们失联了很长一段时间，除了在街上打个招呼外没有真正的联系，但我个人从未真正放弃过那个承诺。
I have to say, that shocked me. I guess I expected him to say that he was angry, or used to be angry. But I never expected this.
我必须说，这让我震惊。我猜他会说他很生气，或者曾经很生气。但我从未预料到会是这样。
Well, you said that you would be there forever. So hell yeah, yes, absolutely. You're still on hold, baby.
好吧，你说过你会永远陪着我。所以当然，天哪，是的，绝对。你还在履行合约呢，宝贝。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Hear my nervous laugh? I was so freaked out by this that I didn't know how to respond. I couldn't respond. In fact, I was so disoriented, that we spent the rest of the hour on tape gabbing about old times, old boyfriends. And when we left, things felt somehow messier and less resolved than even before we talked. I'd spent a decade feeling bad about a promise I broke, and now the promise was back? So a week later, I called Joseph up again.
听到我紧张的笑声了吗？我被这事儿搞得如此不知所措，以至于我不知道该如何回应。我无法回应。事实上，我太混乱了，以至于录音剩下的时间我们都在闲聊往事和旧情人。当我们离开时，事情感觉比谈话前更加凌乱、更没解决。我花了几十年时间因为违背了承诺而感到难过，而现在，这个承诺又回来了？所以一周后，我再次打电话给约瑟夫。
So when we talked before, and you said that the promise was still in force, and I was still on the hook, I was really shocked. And I couldn't really say anything. And I wanted to ask you if you were serious.
所以当我们上次谈话时，你说承诺依然有效，我还欠着你，我真的很震惊。我当时真的说不出话来。我想问你是认真的吗。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Of course it's still in effect, Dan. Because, well, I look at it this way. I just know that you're around if I ever needed you. But it's an abstract sort of hook, Dan. It's not something that I'd probably ever hold you to. You want to be off the hook?
当然有效，丹。因为，好吧，我是这么看的。我只是知道如果你需要的话，你在身边。但这是一种抽象的牵挂，丹。这不是我会真的拿这个来要求你的东西。你想摆脱这个束缚吗？
[LAUGHTER] You do. It's OK.
[笑声] 你确实想。没关系。
He was right. I wanted to be off the hook.
他是对的。我想摆脱这个束缚。
Can you release me from the promise?
你能解除我的承诺吗？
Absolutely. I do release you from the promise. You're let out, Dan.
绝对可以。我确实解除了你的承诺。你自由了，丹。
And then, suddenly, it was like the air cleared between us, as if finally putting this promise to rest allowed a sweetness that had been missing back into our relationship. And Joseph actually ended up telling me how much the promise, such as it was, meant to him at the time.
然后，突然间，空气仿佛在我们之间变得清新，仿佛最终把这个承诺放下，让一种缺失已久的甜蜜回到了我们的关系中。约瑟夫最终还告诉我，当时那个承诺对他来说有多重要。
I didn't have anybody else make me any promises with that conviction.
我没让别人给过我那么坚定的承诺。
I meant it.
我是认真的。
I know that. And I appreciate it. And I know it for what it was-- what it is, and what it was.
我知道。我很感激。我知道那意味着什么——它是什么，它曾经是什么。
Sometimes, I wonder how many guys like me there are out there. Joseph wasn't the only gay man who got up off his deathbed in 1996. So I expect I'm not the only ex-boyfriend who made a solemn promise to be there always, but who ended up embarrassed, unsure of what to do or how to behave once the drugs transformed a six-month commitment into decades.
有时，我想知道像我这样的人在外面还有多少。1996年，约瑟夫不是唯一一个从临终病床上站起来的同性恋男人。所以我估计我不是唯一一个做出庄严承诺要永远相随，却在药物将六个月的承诺转化为数十年后，陷入尴尬、不知所措的前男友。
In the days since Joseph and I talked, I kept wondering why I couldn't leave him believing that the promise, the one I made with such conviction, was still in force. Why not let him think that I'll be there? But I wanted us, after all this time, to return to normal, to be normal ex-boyfriends in the normal, sloppy way that people relate to their exes.
在约瑟夫和我谈话后的几天里，我一直想为什么我不能让他相信那个我怀着如此坚定信心做出的承诺依然有效。为什么不让他觉得我会一直在那儿呢？但我希望我们在这么久之后，回归正常，像普通的前任那样，以一种普通、粗糙的方式与前任相处。
We might be there for each other. We might not. We'll see. I guess what I really wanted was to start treating him like a man with his whole life ahead of him, a man who doesn't need me anymore, or deathbeds, or promises like the one I made him so many years ago.
我们可能会互相帮助。也可能不会。到时候再说。我想我真正想要的是开始像对待一个有着完整未来的人那样对待他，一个不再需要我，不再需要临终病床，不再需要我多年前对他那种承诺的人。
Dan Savage writes the syndicated column, "Savage Love," and has written several books, most recently, The . Commitment .
丹·萨维奇撰写辛迪加专栏《萨维奇的爱》，并著有几本书，最近的一本是《承诺》。
[MUSIC - "THE CAT CAME BACK" BY HEADACHE CITY]
[音乐 - 头痛城市乐队演唱《猫又回来了》]
Act Two, Political Cat. OK, speaking of creatures who you thought were gone who eerily return from oblivion to walk among us, the living, why won't John Kerry just go away? Why is he still out there, giving speeches and TV interviews, and acting like somebody who thinks that someday, he might still be President? Why do I keep seeing his gray, zombie-like face, intoning in that intonation he has, you know, that intoning where it's like he is almost human, but not quite human, sounding defensive, even when he's on the attack?
第二幕，政治猫。好吧，说到那些你以为已经消失，却又离奇地从遗忘中归来，行走在生者之间的生物，为什么约翰·克里就不肯走开呢？为什么他还在那里，发表演讲和接受电视采访，表现得好像认为有一天他还能成为总统？为什么我一直看到他那张灰白、像僵尸一样的脸，用他那种语调说话？你知道，那种语调仿佛他接近人类，但又不完全是人类，听起来充满防备，即便是在他发起攻击的时候？
Tim, that's not what I've suggested. And it's really important to look at what I've proposed. The first step is, you've got to have a government.
蒂姆，那不是我建议的。看看我提议的东西很重要。第一步，你必须得有个政府。
On Meet the Press a few months ago, he was as impenetrable as ever. He was arguing for the US to withdraw from Iraq. And at some point, Tim Russert points out that this might lead to total chaos, an all-out civil war, an invasion by Iran.
几个月前在《与媒体见面》节目上，他依然让人无法理解。他主张美国从伊拉克撤军。在某一点上，蒂姆·拉瑟特指出这可能会导致全面混乱、全面的内战，以及伊朗的入侵。
And Kerry, and maybe this is unfair, but Kerry gave the kind of response that pretty much, I would say, lost him the Presidential race. He said, and this is kind of a counter-intuitive thing to say when you first hear it, so I'm going to say this slowly. He said, "A US withdrawal plus diplomatic pressure might just finally force everybody in Iraq to figure out how to live together." But listen to how he says it, OK? This is classic Kerry, which means, and all due respect here, perhaps a tad long-winded.
克里——也许这么说不公平——克里给出的回应，我可以说，基本上让他输掉了总统竞选。他说，这是个反直觉的说法，所以我会慢慢说。他说，“美国撤军加上外交压力，可能最终会迫使伊拉克的每个人学会如何生活在一起。”但听听他是怎么说的，好吗？这是典型的克里式风格，意思是——恕我直言——也许有点冗长。
But that's not the way to do it, Tim. What you need, and what I've suggested, is that you have a Dayton Accords-like summit where you bring all the parties together. And I mean all the parties-- you need to bring Iraq's neighbors together. Khalilzad has now been authorized to talk to the Iranians. Bring the Iranians. Bring the Syrians. Bring the Jordanians, the Saudis, the Egyptians, and others. Now it may be that ultimately you can't find a resolution on the constitutional issues, and you have to embrace something like Les Gelb's original proposal, the former head of the Council on Foreign Relations, who said, you may have to divide it up into three parts. I don't know the answer to that today.
但那不是办法，蒂姆。你所需要的是，也是我所建议的，你需要一个类似代顿协议的峰会，把所有政党聚在一起。我是说所有政党——你需要把伊拉克的邻国召集起来。哈利勒扎德现在已经被授权与伊朗人对话。带上伊朗人。带上叙利亚人。带上约旦人、沙特人、埃及人和其他人。现在，最终可能在宪法问题上找不到决议，你可能不得不接受莱斯·盖尔布——前外交关系委员会主席——的原始提议，他说，你可能不得不把它分成三部分。我现在不知道那个答案。
Like I say, classic Kerry. He throws around a lot of names and a lot of references in a sort of shorthand that just doesn't shed a lot of light for most of us. So as a result, he's both stunningly boring and completely unconvincing at the same time. So even though he may well be right, you know, he may be right. A combination of withdrawal from Iraq and diplomacy at the same time, that might be our only hope right now in Iraq. When you hear him say it, you just don't believe it.
正如我所说，典型的克里。他用一种简写方式抛出很多名字和参考资料，对我们大多数人来说，这并没有说明什么问题。结果就是，他既令人震惊地无聊，又完全没有说服力。所以尽管他很可能是对的，你知道，他可能是对的。从伊拉克撤军和同时进行外交，那可能是我们现在在伊拉克唯一的希望。当你听他说这些时，你就是不相信。
There are a lot of different ways to understand why President Bush won the election in 2004: money, and organizing, and demographics, and the way they draw the lines in those congressional districts, and all that stuff, right, values, the religious right. I want to make the case here for a simple explanation. It's Kerry's fault.
有很多不同的方式来理解布什总统为什么在2004年赢得选举：金钱、组织、人口统计学，以及他们在国会选区划线的方式，诸如此类，对吧，价值观，宗教右翼。我想在这里为一种简单的解释做辩护。是克里的错。
I want to emphasize, this is my personal view, not the view of NPR News, Public Radio International, this radio station. This is my view. My view of Kerry was set forever the night of the first 2004 presidential debate, which you may remember was a pretty big night for him. It's the first time he squared off against President Bush one on one. I watched this thing from the home of Dr. Gig Hackett in Cincinnati, in the swing state of Ohio.
我想强调，这是我个人的观点，不是NPR新闻、国际公共广播电台或这个电台的观点。这是我的观点。我对克里的看法在2004年第一次总统辩论之夜被永久定格了，那对你来说可能是一个大日子。那是他第一次一对一面对布什总统。我在辛辛那提吉格·哈克特医生的家中观看了这场辩论，那是在摇摆州俄亥俄州。
Hi, welcome. Hey. Come on in.
嗨，欢迎。嘿。进来吧。
There were seven people there, and all of their votes were up for grabs. Three leaned towards President Bush. Two leaned towards Kerry. Two were completely undecided the night of this first debate.
那里有七个人，他们的选票都在摇摆。三个人倾向布什总统。两个人倾向克里。两个人在这场第一次辩论之夜完全没有决定。
And what was fascinating and kind of notable is that all seven were upset with President Bush. Even the supporters of President Bush were upset with them. All seven thought that he was doing a lousy job in Iraq, and with the economy in Ohio.
引人注目且值得注意的是，所有七个人都对布什总统感到不满。即使是布什总统的支持者也对他不满。七个人都认为他在伊拉克以及俄亥俄州的经济方面做得一团糟。
Some of them found him outright alarming on abortion and social issues. Even his supporters in the group were not happy with the idea they were going to have to vote for him again. And so they all sat down in front of the TV with the feeling that all Kerry had to do was just give them a reason, give them a reason to vote for him.
其中一些人对他处理堕胎和社会问题的方式感到惊恐。即使是小组里的支持者，对不得不再次投票给他也不高兴。所以他们都坐在电视机前，感觉克里只需要给他们一个理由，给他们一个投票给他的理由。
Yeah, they'd seen the ads. They'd seen the news. But they actually still did not get what it was that Kerry stood for. What was he going to do for the country?
是的，他们看过广告。看过新闻。但他们实际上仍然不明白克里代表什么。他要为国家做什么？
I do have an indistinct feeling about Kerry. I'd like to know more about his views on the national security issues.
我对克里确实有一种模糊的感觉。我想多了解他在国家安全问题上的观点。
Well first, I need to get to know him as a politician.
首先，我需要了解他作为一个政治家的样子。
To make a long story short, they began the night unsure of what he stood for, and they ended the night the same way. Nationally, this debate helped Kerry's poll numbers. But here in this Ohio basement, they were unmoved. They were deeply skeptical.
长话短说，他们晚上开始时不知道他代表什么，结束时依然不知道。在全国范围内，这场辩论有助于克里的民调数据。但在这个俄亥俄州的地下室里，他们毫不动容。他们深表怀疑。
Kerry would lay out a four-point plan for what he was going to do in Iraq. And I would turn to the group and I would say, OK, what do you think? And they would all be like, but what's he going to do? How is that so different from what the President's going to do?
克里会提出一个关于他在伊拉克要做什么的四点计划。我会转向小组说，好吧，你们怎么看？他们都会说，但他到底要做什么？这跟总统要做的事有什么不同？
And I would say, well, he just said his four points. And they'd say, yes, yes, yes, but what's the big picture? What's he stand for?
我会说，嗯，他刚才说了他的四点计划。他们会说，是的，是的，是的，但大局是什么？他代表什么？
To be fair, I think part of Kerry's problem was that months of Republican political ads had convinced all of these people that he was a waffler, a prevaricator, that he didn't stand for anything in particular. But Kerry's problem as a candidate was that he seemed incapable of doing or saying anything to overcome or counteract any of that, any of what his opponents were saying about him, which, these days, for better or worse, is an important political skill. Here's Dr. Hackett.
公平地说，我认为克里的部分问题在于，数月的共和党政治广告已经让这些人相信他是一个骑墙派、推卸责任者，他什么都不代表。但克里作为候选人的问题在于，他似乎无法做出或说出任何事情来克服或抵消这些，任何他的对手说他的坏话，这在今天，无论好坏，都是一项重要的政治技能。这是哈克特医生。
No, that's the whole point. That's the whole point I'm making. I think Kerry says things. That's why I don't like Kerry, because I don't trust him. I don't trust what he says. When he says something, I don't know if he really believes that or not.
不，这就是重点。这就是我所说的重点。我认为克里说了一些事情。这就是我不喜欢克里的原因，因为我不信任他。我不信任他说的话。当他说某件事时，我不知道他是否真的相信。
So even when John Kerry pointed out, truthfully, correctly, policy blunders and missteps his opponent had made, nobody in this room believed him. Even when he's in the right, he doesn't convince people. In the last few months, John Kerry's had a little wave of media attention, after he proposed setting a deadline to withdraw American forces from Iraq. He hasn't actually announced that he's running for president again, but he sure seems like he is keeping that possibility open.
所以即使约翰·克里真实、正确地指出他的对手犯下的政策错误和失误时，屋里也没有人相信他。即使他是对的，他也无法说服人们。在过去几个月里，约翰·克里在提出设定撤出驻伊拉克美军的最后期限后，媒体对他有了一点关注。他并没有正式宣布再次竞选总统，但他看起来确实把这种可能性敞开了。
And I'm not proud of this, and I'm just saying this now as one voter to another. And is anybody else feeling this too? When I'm flipping channels, and I see him making a speech, or giving an interview, I feel this moment of rage, actually.
我对此并不骄傲，我只是作为一个选民对另一个选民这么说。还有人有这种感觉吗？当我在翻台看到他发表演讲或接受采访时，我实际上感到了那种愤怒。
Like why do you still walk the earth? Why do I still have to keep seeing your face? Don't you understand? We took a vote. We all took a vote in the most literal way possible. We took a vote. We don't like you.
就像你为什么还走在地球上？为什么我还得一直看到你的脸？你不明白吗？我们已经投票了。我们以最字面的方式投了票。我们投了票。我们不喜欢你。
I see him, and it's like seeing some ex-girlfriend that you don't want to run into on the street. Why do I still have to think about you now, after everything? Stop running for president, John Kerry. You had your chance, John Kerry. If you couldn't win that election, when the deficit was ballooning, and job creation wasn't so great, and we were losing ground in a tough war, and almost half the country hated your opponent before you even opened your mouth-- it's not going to get any easier than that one.
我看到他，就像看到某个你在街上不想碰到的前女友。为什么经过这一切后，我现在还得想到你？别再竞选总统了，约翰·克里。你已经有机会了，约翰·克里。如果你不能赢下那次选举——当时赤字在膨胀，就业创造也不太好，我们在一场艰苦的战争中节节败退，而且在你开口之前几乎半个国家都讨厌你的对手——那再也没有比那更容易的了。
Do something else, John Kerry. Do something else with your many skills. You're a civic-minded man. Go run a charity. Go run Harvard. Go run Yale. They're smart enough to actually understand what you're trying to say when you open your mouth and talk.
做点别的吧，约翰·克里。用你众多的技能做点别的。你是个有公民意识的人。去经营一家慈善机构。去经营哈佛。去经营耶鲁。他们足够聪明，能真正听懂你开口说话时想表达什么。
Coming up, a family that keeps losing one of its children, who keeps returning. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program comes back.
接下来，一个家庭不断失去孩子，孩子却不断归来。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目回来后为您播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today 's show, The Cat Came Back, stories of animals, people, things that will not go away, that return to haunt you, even if you want them to go away. We've arrived at Act  Three of our show, Baby Cat. This is a story of a person who goes away and comes back, from Michael Beaumier.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目《猫又回来了》，讲述那些不肯离去的动物、人、事的故事，它们回来纠缠你，即使你想让它们离开。我们现在进行到节目的第三幕，婴儿猫。这是一个关于一个人离开又回来的故事，来自迈克尔·博米尔。
My parents have been married for something like 750 years. And in all that time, they've only had one argument, one long, constant argument that never ends, an argument that they're each dead-set on winning: an unresolved disagreement over the number of children they actually have. To be fair, my parents did have a lot of children. And after the first four or five, it probably got hard to keep track. No one disputes that there are two girls, Anne and Katie. The trouble was, as it always is with the boys.
我父母结婚大概有750年了。在这段时间里，他们只有一场争论，一场没完没了的持续性争论，一场他们每个人都下定决心要赢的争论：关于他们实际拥有的孩子数量的问题。公平地说，我父母确实有很多孩子。在头四个或五个孩子之后，可能很难记得清。没人争议那两个女孩，安妮和凯蒂。麻烦总是在男孩身上。
My mother counts six. My dad says seven. We are, in order, Jack, Pat, Mike, Matt, Casey, Colin, and Paul. Mom is Irish. When the new baby arrived, we all knew the drill. Bets placed on gender and the date of birth would have to be paid, sleeping arrangements rearranged, a crib set up. Our grandmother would stay a night or two, 'til mom and baby came home. By the time mom was pregnant with her ninth child, this had become routine, no big deal. We were a well-oiled machine, until baby number nine.
我母亲算的是六个。我父亲说是七个。我们依次是杰克、帕特、迈克、马特、凯西、科林和保罗。妈是爱尔兰人。新婴儿到来时，我们都知道套路。性别和出生日期的赌注得付，睡觉安排得重新调整，婴儿床得搭好。祖母会待一两个晚上，直到妈妈和宝宝回家。当妈妈怀上第九个孩子时，这已经成了例行公事，没什么大不了。我们是一台运转良好的机器，直到第九个婴儿。
Dad didn't come home that night, nor the next day, nor for many days after. It was a shock when Dad reappeared, exhausted and unshaven. And when he spoke, it was with a tone we'd only ever heard him address to grownups. Mom was very sick, he told us. The baby was sick, too. Things looked bad. He was going to be at the hospital a lot. And grandma was going to take care of us. We needed to be extra well-behaved. No fighting, no complaining, no fires. Let the dog's fur grow back for once. Be good. There was no "or else," no threat of punishment, no offer of reward. He wasn't asking.
那天晚上爸爸没回家，第二天也没回来，之后好几天都没回来。爸爸精疲力竭、胡子拉碴地重新出现时，这真是个冲击。他说话的语气，我们只听过他用那种语气对成年人说过话。妈妈病得很重，他告诉我们。婴儿也病了。情况看起来很糟。他要在医院待很久。祖母会照顾我们。我们需要表现得格外好。不打架，不抱怨，不玩火。让狗的毛长一次。要乖。没有“否则”，没有惩罚的威胁，没有奖励的承诺。他不是在请求。
Grandma morosely insisted that we comb our hair and keep our voices down. She declared that matches, scissors, knives, glue, duct tape, and the mallet used to tenderize meat were not toys, and that from here on out, we had to make our beds. But the worst part was no fighting. No fighting, was she serious? Not even sucker punches?
祖母忧郁地坚持要我们梳头，保持安静。她宣布火柴、剪刀、刀子、胶水、胶带和用来嫩肉的槌子不是玩具，从现在起，我们必须整理床铺。但最糟糕的是不准打架。不准打架，她是认真的吗？连偷袭都不行？
Days turned to weeks, and weeks into months. No one knew exactly what had happened, and no one was brave enough to ask. But we figured out the basics. The baby had come. Something went wrong. And mom had nearly died. When we were finally allowed to visit her in the hospital, we could only go in small groups, two or three of us at most. We didn't need to be told to behave ourselves. Mom found this unnerving. "Why aren't you fighting?" she'd ask from her bed. "They aren't like this at home, I swear," she would assure the nurses. "Who are you people? Somebody hit someone already." But Dad would shake his head, no. And we'd cower by the door, afraid to do anything that might upset her.
日子变成周，周变成月。没人知道到底发生了什么，也没人勇敢到去问。但我们弄清楚了基本情况。宝宝出生了。出了点问题。妈妈差点死了。当我们最终被允许在医院探望她时，我们只能分批去，最多两三个。不需要有人告诉我们表现得乖一点。妈妈发现这令人不安。“你们为什么不打架？”她从床上问。“他们在家不是这样的，我发誓，”她向护士保证。“你们是谁？有人快去打人呀。”但爸爸会摇头，不。我们躲在门口，不敢做任何可能让她心烦的事。
The baby was barely mentioned. None of us younger kids saw Paul, as they'd named him, until finally, very late that summer, he and mom were well enough to come home and got a decidedly low-key reception, especially compared to the raucous introductions new babies usually received. No one tried feeding Paul candy or introducing him to the dog by putting them both in the playpen. We weren't very clear on what Dad meant by "Paul is special needs." And when we gathered around the crib to finally get a look at him, he hardly seemed like the cause of so much trouble. He looked like any baby, except for the terrible shakes that would suddenly overwhelm him, and how his eyes would roll back in his head. The seizures were constant and brutal, overtaking his tiny body several times a minute. Had I been old enough to understand what was happening, I would not have been able to bear it.
宝宝几乎没被提到。我们这些年幼的孩子直到那个夏天快结束时才见到他们取名保罗的保罗，最后回到家时，接待相当低调，特别是与新婴儿通常受到的吵闹欢迎相比。没人尝试喂保罗糖果，或者通过把他们俩都放进游戏围栏来介绍他给狗认识。我们不太清楚爸爸说的“保罗有特殊需求”是什么意思。当我们聚集在婴儿床周围终于看到他时，他看起来根本不像引起这么多麻烦的原因。他看起来像任何婴儿，除了突然淹没他的可怕颤抖，以及他的眼睛如何翻向脑后。癫痫发作是持续且残酷的，每分钟好几次地占领他娇小的身体。如果我年龄大到能理解发生了什么，我将无法承受。
Being children, and being us, we immediately nicknamed him Shakes. We weren't allowed to hold him, but we tried to outdo one another impersonating him, convulsing on the floor, falling over each other, fluttering and rolling our eyes, as Paul did. But eventually, even we could see that this baby required a great deal of care. There was no set routine with Paul, as there is with most newborns. He didn't eat normally, didn't sleep according to any set schedule, couldn't be left to himself. The task of caring for him soon proved overwhelming.
作为孩子，又是我们这样，我们立刻给他起了个绰号叫“颤抖者”。我们不被允许抱他，但我们试图互相模仿他，在地板上抽搐，互相跌倒，扑腾着翻白眼，就像保罗做的那样。但最终，连我们都能看出这个婴儿需要大量的照料。保罗没有固定的作息，不像大多数新生儿那样。他吃得不正常，睡觉没有固定的日程，不能独自留着。照顾他的任务很快变得让人难以承受。
In hindsight, it was probably crazy to think that Mom could take care of eight children and a very sick newborn after nearly dying herself. He was with us for only a matter of weeks, really, before the decision was made. I don't remember the day they took him away, or saying goodbye, but we didn't see Paul again for almost two years.
事后看来，认为妈妈能在差点死后照顾八个孩子和一个病得很重的婴儿，大概是疯了。他真的只和我们在一起几周，决定就做出了。我不记得他们带他走的那天，也不记得说再见，但我们几乎两年没再见到保罗。
A gloom settled over us after Paul was gone-- not anxiety, not tragedy, either, but this odd, nagging feeling of incompleteness. Someone was supposed to be there, and he wasn't. Paul's absence was acute, a presence in itself. And it was especially hard on Mom. Occasionally, she and Dad would disappear without a word, telling us only later that they'd gone to the place where Paul was, an institution of some kind in a town nearby. Mom would just suddenly want to see him, sometimes on the spur of the moment, and Dad never said no. Afterwards, when we asked, Dad would tell us that Paul was fine, but there were never really any details. Mom would usually go upstairs after these journeys, shut her bedroom door, close the curtains, and crawl into bed.
保罗走后，忧郁笼罩着我们——不是焦虑，也不是悲剧，而是一种奇怪的、挥之不去的残缺感。有人应该在那里，但他不在。保罗的缺席很敏锐，本身就是一种存在。这对妈妈来说尤其艰难。偶尔，她和爸爸会一言不发地消失，只在后来告诉我们他们去了保罗在的地方，附近小镇上的某种机构。妈妈只是突然想见他，有时是在冲动下，爸爸从不说不。后来，当我们问时，爸爸会告诉我们保罗很好，但从来没有什么细节。妈妈在这些旅程后通常会上楼，关上卧室门，拉上窗帘，爬进被窝。
When Paul finally died, two days before his second birthday, it was like a bad spell had been broken. There would be a funeral, and sadness, and a terrible sense of loss, but there would also be an ending, finally, instead of the in-between place where he and all the rest of us had lived for so long. Because we hadn't seen him since he was an infant, Paul had become to us kids less a person than a situation.
当保罗在两岁生日前两天最终去世时，就像一个恶咒被打破了。会有葬礼，会有悲伤，会有可怕的失落感，但也会有一个结局，终于，而不是他和他剩下的我们一直生活了这么久的中间地带。因为自从他还是个婴儿我们就没见过他，保罗对我们这些孩子来说与其说是人，不如说是一种状况。
All that changed at his wake. The casket was a tiny thing. You could put your arm around it. I don't know why I expected to see a baby, but that wasn't what he was. His hair had grown in, dark and full. And his features had become more pronounced and solid, the nose, the shape of his mouth, his thick, bushy eyebrows-- a face so familiar, because it was mine, the face I shared with the boys gathered around me peering into the tiny coffin.
这一切在他的守灵仪式上改变了。棺材是个小东西。你的手臂可以环住它。我不知道为什么我期望看到一个婴儿，但他不是那样的。他的头发长出来了，深色且浓密。他的五官变得更加突出和结实，鼻子，嘴巴的形状，他浓密的眉毛——一张如此熟悉的脸，因为那是我的脸，我与聚集在我周围盯着微小棺材的男孩们共享的脸。
My brother Collin, now the youngest brother again, only six years old, couldn't keep his hands off Paul, holding his tiny fingers and touching his face. I understood exactly what he was feeling, the shock and surprise of it. Suddenly, he seemed like our brother. Suddenly, he seemed like one of us.
我弟弟科林，现在又是最小的弟弟，才六岁，不肯把手从保罗身上拿开，握着他细小的手指，摸他的脸。我完全理解他的感觉，那种震惊和惊喜。突然，他看起来像我们的兄弟。突然，他看起来像我们中的一员。
Personally, I thought he looked like Pat, though from certain angles, he seemed more like Casey. Matt said he was a dead ringer for Jack, and immediately regretted his choice of words. Pat said he looked like a combination of Colin crossed with me, except without braces, which I took to be an affront, and said so. Pat told me to stop being a jerk in church. And Matt pointed out that we were in a funeral home, not a church, and added the word "butthead" for good measure.
就我个人而言，我觉得他看起来像帕特，尽管从某些角度看，他似乎更像凯西。马特说他长得跟杰克一模一样，并立刻后悔了他选择的用词。帕特说他看起来像科林和我的结合体，只是没有戴牙套，我把这当作一种侮辱，并说出来了。帕特叫我在教堂里别像个混蛋。马特指出我们在殡仪馆，不是教堂，并加了“混蛋”这个词以示加强。
Then Anne shoved Matt, and Matt shoved Anne back. And Katie, four years old and now armed with a brand new word, screamed "Stop it, you buttheads," at the top of her little lungs. Mom either laughed until she cried, or vice versa. Dad made us all go sit down.
然后安妮推了马特，马特推了回去。凯蒂，四岁大，现在掌握了一个崭新的词，用她那小小肺部的最大音量尖叫道：“停下，你们这些混蛋。”妈妈要么笑得哭了，要么反之亦然。爸爸让我们都去坐下。
We buried Paul. And we cried. And Colin dug a little hole over the grave and put some of his tiny plastic dinosaurs in for Paul to have. And then we went home and fought our way into adulthood, breaking into food fights and putting firecrackers down each other's pants, pushing one another out of windows, and filling each other's socks with jelly.
我们埋葬了保罗。我们哭了。科林在墓地上挖了一个小洞，放了一些他的微小塑料恐龙让保罗拥有。然后我们回家，打闹着步入成年，引发食物大战，把鞭炮塞进对方的裤子里，把对方从窗户推出去，把果冻塞进对方的袜子里。
It was hard not to notice that these epic battles were, more often than not, instigated by our mother, who never seemed happier than when she was surveying the devastation, a gin and tonic in one hand, a cigarette in the other, a smirk of utter satisfaction on her lips. Mom would arm us with spray paint and fake IDs. She expected us to sneak out for midnight keggers and illicit cigarettes.
很难不注意到这些史诗般的战斗往往是由我们的母亲煽动的，她似乎最幸福的时候就是当她在审视破坏，一手拿着金汤力，一手拿着香烟，嘴角带着绝对满足的坏笑时。妈妈会用喷漆和假身份证武装我们。她期待我们溜出去参加午夜啤酒派对和抽非法的烟。
She was actually quite adamant about such adventures, because she knew what the alternative was. She'd been raised in a house engulfed in grief. Her mother had been made an Irish widow at a very young age, and never stopped mourning. Mom refused to give herself or us up to it.
她对此类冒险实际上相当坚定，因为她知道替代品是什么。她是在一个被悲伤吞噬的房子里长大的。她的母亲在很年轻时就成了爱尔兰寡妇，从未停止哀悼。妈妈拒绝让自己或我们屈服于它。
Nobody talked about Paul. His birthday went uncelebrated. And his life and death, while never explicitly denied, was a forbidden topic. We'd visit his grave, of course. But we all knew not to bring up that time, or mention his name, because none of us could bear the look of pain that would appear in our parents' eyes. We knew that sometimes they would go to the cemetery by themselves to see him. And even years later, after all of us kids had grown up and moved out, and begun families of our own, after they'd sold the house and left town themselves, they would drive for hours, sometimes on the spur of the moment, still, just to be there.
没人谈论保罗。他的生日没有庆祝。而他的生命和死亡，虽然从未明确否认，却是一个禁忌话题。我们当然会去扫墓。但我们都知道不要提那段时间，或者提起他的名字，因为我们没有人能忍受父母眼中流露出的痛苦神色。我们知道有时他们会独自去墓地看他。即使多年后，我们这些孩子长大离家，组建了自己的家庭，他们卖掉房子离开城镇后，他们依然会开车几个小时，有时是心血来潮，只是为了去那里。
The living mean more than the dead. And the living go on and they forget. But sometimes the elements conspire to bring the past and the present together again, and the dead remind you of all they once were. There was a winter of extraordinary snow, followed by a spring of heavy, incessant rain. Rivers rose, the waters came, and a terrible flood engulfed our old, North Dakota hometown. Half the city was underwater, the bottom half. Unfortunately, the top half was still quite dry. No one knows how the fire started exactly, but it jumped from building to building, burning everything straight down until the fire met the water. When it was over, nearly everything was destroyed, except the cemetery.
生者比死者意义重大。生者继续生活，他们会忘记。但有时元素会勾结起来让过去和现在再次汇合，死者会提醒你他们曾经的一切。有一个积雪特别多的冬天，接着是一个大雨连绵的春天。河流上涨，水来了，一场可怕的洪水淹没了我们老北达科他州的家乡。半个城市都在水下，下半部分。不幸的是，上半部分仍然很干。没人确切知道火是怎么起来的，但它从建筑物跳到建筑物，烧毁了一切，直到火遇到水。结束时，几乎一切都被摧毁，除了墓地。
Maybe it was because they didn't like driving so far for so long, or maybe they just didn't want him to be there all alone, in the middle of nowhere, with no one to mow the grass or put flowers on his headstone, or remember who he was. But at some point, my parents hatched their little plan for Paul. They'd have him disinterred and moved to where they were in upper Michigan, where they'd gone to live, to be buried next to my grandmother. The casket was flown as far as Wisconsin, where for reasons that still remain somewhat murky, my parents decided they'd finish Paul's journey on their own. My father had gotten very specific measurements of Paul's casket, the length and width and weight, and he'd borrowed a pickup truck that would accommodate the task.
也许是因为他们不喜欢开那么久的车，或者也许他们只是不想让他孤零零地待在那儿，在荒郊野外，没人割草，没人往墓碑上放花，也没人记得他是谁。但在某个时候，我父母为保罗制定了他们的小计划。他们要让他被起出，搬到他们在上密歇根州居住的地方，和我的祖母埋在一起。棺材被飞运到威斯康星州，出于依然有些模糊的原因，我父母决定自己完成保罗的旅程。我父亲得到了保罗棺材的具体尺寸，长度、宽度和重量，他借了一辆能容纳这项任务的小货车。
But apparently, to the surprise of probably no one except my parents, the rules about moving a body tend to be rather strict. You can't just haul around a casket that's been stuck in the ground for more than 20 years. The casket itself has to go into a special container of its own, one that's clearly marked and labeled.
但显然，除了我父母之外可能没人感到惊讶，关于移动遗体的规定往往相当严格。你不能随随便便拖着一具已经在土里待了20多年的棺材到处跑。棺材本身必须放入一个特殊的专用容器中，一个标记明确、标签齐全的容器。
Dad didn't think it was as funny as the shipping dispatcher did when the box proved to be too long to fit in the truck. He didn't think it was funny when the box was strapped in using extension cords. And he certainly didn't think it was funny when he had to pull the truck over to the side of the highway every 10 miles, where he and my mother would have to get out and push the box marked "Caution: human remains" back into the truck as cars zipped past, the other drivers' mouths hanging open, their eyes agog, their necks snapping around at the sight of two old people and their box of bones.
当盒子证明太长塞不进货车时，爸爸并不觉得这像运输调度员觉得的那么好笑。当盒子用延长线捆在车上时，他没觉得好笑。当他不得不每隔10英里就把车停在高速公路路边，他和妈妈不得不下车把那个标有“小心：人类遗骸”的盒子推回车上，而汽车呼啸而过，其他司机嘴巴张大，眼睛瞪得圆圆的，脖子在看到两个老人和他们那箱骨头时咔嚓转动时，他绝对没觉得好笑。
But Mom loved every moment. Burying a son once is tragic, but twice, well, that's a habit. She took great pleasure in calling each of her children after arriving home, letting us know that she and Dad were back from a long journey, that our father was exhausted from the drive, and that a box containing our beloved baby brother was currently sitting in her garage.
但妈妈享受每一刻。埋葬一个儿子一次是悲剧，但两次，好吧，那是一种习惯。她在大约回家后给每个孩子打电话，让我们知道她和爸爸刚从一段长途旅行回来，我们的父亲因为驾驶而筋疲力尽，而一个装着我们心爱的弟弟的盒子目前正坐在她的车库里。
There was an old, almost forgotten glee in her voice. We all noticed it. She seemed to revel in our shock, and laughed at our perplexed horror. She'd never joked about Paul, never. And sure, the jokes were utterly tasteless and wholly inappropriate, but it was nice to see her old, wicked personality kick in. Suddenly, Paul wasn't off-limits.
她的声音里有一种古老的、几乎被遗忘的欢快。我们都注意到了。她似乎陶醉于我们的震惊，嘲笑我们困惑的恐惧。她从未拿保罗开过玩笑，从来没有。当然，这些笑话完全没品且极度不合适，但看到她那古老的、邪恶的人格显露出来还是很不错的。突然，保罗不再是禁区了。
"They're getting creepy," my brother Matt said. "Well, that's what happens when you get old," Colin said. "You never throw anything away." "Remind me to be cremated," I told my brother Casey. "It won't matter," Casey responded. "That'll just make you easier to cart around wherever they go." "Paul's obviously their favorite," Pat said dryly. "Of course, it's easy to love a kid that you don't have to tell to shut up." And there he was. Paul was back among us, our brother at last.
“他们变得令人毛骨悚然了，”我哥哥马特说。“好吧，这就是当你老了会发生的事，”科林说。“你永远不会扔掉任何东西。”“提醒我一定要火化，”我告诉哥哥凯西。“那没用，”凯西回应说。“那只会让你更容易被他们拖着随身携带。”“保罗显然是他们的最爱，”帕特干巴巴地说。“当然，爱一个你不用告诉他闭嘴的孩子很容易。”他就在那儿。保罗终于回到了我们中间，终于成了我们的兄弟。
We didn't even know we had missed him. We didn't know we could miss him. Years of silence and confusion were, overnight, replaced with deeply inappropriate dead baby jokes, and everyone's favorite, sibling rivalry.
我们甚至不知道我们错过了他。我们不知道我们竟然会想念他。多年的沉默和困惑在一夜之间被极其不适宜的死婴笑话和每个人最喜欢的兄弟姐妹竞争所取代。
Where, we wondered, would they be taking Paul next? Disneyland? We never got to go to Disneyland. "You never took us anywhere," we cried. "How could we?" Mom told us. "You kids were always fighting."
我们好奇他们接下来会带保罗去哪儿？迪士尼乐园？我们从没去过迪士尼乐园。“你们从来没带我们去任何地方，”我们哭诉。“怎么可能？”妈妈告诉我们，“你们这些孩子总是打架。”
But mom was clearly the worst. She relished her gross-out humor and always managed to do one better. Not long after this, she called each of her sons, one by one, to ask in her most serious and earnest voice if we'd ever had a, you know, bad experience with a priest when we were kids. This was in the middle of the terrible molestation scandals, and she told us that she absolutely, positively wanted to know. One by one, we assured her that nothing of the kind had ever happened, that our priests were good guys, and that no one had ever tried anything, ever.
但妈妈显然是最糟糕的。她沉浸于她的恶心幽默，总是设法更胜一筹。此后不久，她一个接一个地给她的儿子们打电话，用她最严肃、最认真的声音问我们小的时候有没有经历过，你知道的，与牧师的不愉快经历。这正值可怕的骚扰丑闻期间，她告诉我们她绝对、肯定想知道。我们一个接一个地向她保证，没发生过那种事，我们的牧师是好人，从来没人尝试过任何事。
"Well crap," she said. "That's what your brothers said, too. I must have raised the six ugliest boys on the face of the earth." And then she laughed and laughed, delighted that she'd gotten another one on us. Dad's voice would pipe up somewhere behind her, mildly irritated at having to remind her, yet again, not six, seven.
“好吧，该死，”她说。“你们兄弟也这么说。我肯定养了这地球上最丑的六个男孩。”然后她笑啊笑，很高兴又赢了我们一局。爸爸的声音会在她身后某处传出来，因为不得不再次提醒她而略显烦躁——不是六个，是七个。
Michaeul Beaumier, reading an excerpt from his book, I Know You're Out There , which comes out next month. By the way, the town he talks about in that story is Grand Forks, North Dakota.
迈克尔·博米尔，朗读了他即将于下个月出版的著作《我知道你在那里》的片段。顺便说一句，他在那个故事中谈到的城市是北达科他州的大福克斯。
[MUSIC - "THE CAT CAME BACK" BY MIKE TREESE AND DJ RUDE ONE]
[音乐 - 迈克·特里斯和DJ Rude One演唱《猫又回来了》]
Act Four, Refugee Cat. Well, our program today is about people who keep coming back, no matter what. In this act, we look at people in the opposite situation. They're trying to come back, but finding it very, very hard.
第四幕，难民猫。好吧，我们今天的节目是关于那些无论如何都会不断回来的人。在这一幕中，我们看看相反情况的人。他们试图回来，但发现非常、非常困难。
There are many people right now from New Orleans who are trying to get back to New Orleans, but fear they will not have homes to go to, because they were renters in the public housing projects there. Before Hurricane Katrina, there were over 12,000 people like that, thousands more were getting section eight vouchers to help them rent apartments around the city. Since the flood, the Department of Housing and Urban Development has announced that instead of fixing up some of the big housing developments, it's going to tear them down.
现在有很多来自新奥尔良的人试图回到新奥尔良，但担心没有房子可以住，因为他们是那里公共住房项目的租户。卡特里娜飓风之前，有超过12000人是这样，还有成千上万的人拿着第八节代金券，帮助他们在城市周围租公寓。洪水过后，住房和城市发展部宣布，与其修缮一些大型住房开发项目，不如拆除它们。
Four of them are scheduled to go, which means that the 7,500 people who lived in those apartments are going to have to find other places to live. Cheryl Wagner, who lives in New Orleans, has been following all of this. And she has noticed that the guiding principle in this debate seems to be for everybody on all sides, those who want to tear down the projects, and those who want to save them, to make each other, and everybody else, feel as terrible as possible.
有四个项目定于拆除，这意味着住在那里的7500人将不得不找到其他地方居住。住在新奥尔良的谢丽尔·瓦格纳一直在关注这一切。她注意到这场辩论中的指导原则似乎是让每个人——无论各方立场如何，那些想拆除这些项目的人，和那些想保留它们的人——让对方以及所有人感到尽可能糟糕。
This is a story that I like to call "Who Should Be Ashamed of Themselves?" There are few spectator sports quite like watching people in the public housing debate skirmish for the moral high ground. Every time some poor sop points out that bringing back the old buildings the way they were might not be such a good idea, that an awful lot of people have gotten shot in or near New Orleans housing projects, that many units are dilapidated, or that the Housing Authority of New Orleans was failing so miserably that HUD took over years ago, someone counters with, "Y'all should be ashamed of yourself for trying to put all those poor, flooded, old ladies and children out in the street."
这是一个我喜欢称之为“谁该感到羞耻？”的故事。很少有像观看公共住房辩论中人们为争夺道德制高点而发生小冲突这样的观赏性运动了。每当有可怜的笨蛋指出，像原来那样带回旧建筑可能不是一个好主意——有太多人在新奥尔良住房项目里或附近被枪杀，许多单元破旧不堪，或者新奥尔良住房管理局失败得如此惨烈以至于HUD几年前接管了它——就会有人反驳说，“你们所有人为了试图把那些可怜的、被洪水淹没的老太太和孩子赶到街上去，应该感到羞耻。”
On the other hand, some housing activists cried "For shame," when HUD upped the amount of section eight vouchers 35% to address the soaring rents in the post-Katrina rental market, marking perhaps the first time ever that housing activists protested a government agency giving more money to the poor.
另一方面，当HUD将第八节代金券的数额提高了35%以应对卡特里娜飓风后日益高涨的租房市场时，一些住房活动家哭了“羞耻”，这可能是住房活动家第一次抗议政府机构给穷人更多钱。
And then all sorts of middle-class people started protesting, too, writing editorials to the local paper, complaining that HUD was inflating the price of rentals, and squeezing firemen and teachers out of New Orleans in favor of poor people. Legal secretaries are just as flooded, they point out, and no one upped their salaries 35%.
然后各种中产阶级也开始抗议，给当地报纸写社论，抱怨HUD在推高租金价格，把消防员和教师挤出新奥尔良，以支持穷人。他们指出，法律秘书也同样被洪水淹没了，没人给他们涨薪35%。
Some of the people throwing stones at HUD aren't even from New Orleans, much less from the projects. Since the storm, both local and what some here might call "carpetbagging" housing activists have rushed to the scene, clutching "Gentrification equals globalization equals racism equals imperialism equals war" flyers. When activists showed up at meetings of the City Housing Authority protesting the destruction of existing public housing stock, that's when the real shame-off began.
一些向HUD投掷石头的人甚至不是来自新奥尔良，更不用说来自那些项目了。风暴过后，当地和一些人可能称之为“地毯包式”的住房活动家都冲到了现场，手里拿着写着“绅士化等于全球化等于种族主义等于帝国主义等于战争”的传单。当活动家出现在城市住房管理局抗议拆除现有公共住房存量的会议上时，真正的“羞耻大作战”就开始了。
At one meeting, they brought a stressed-out African-American housing administrator close to tears. They accused her of trying to purge New Orleans of other African-Americans, of taking bribes, of not caring. This is a woman who lives in New Orleans and who was stranded for three days on the roof of her office in Gentilly before being rescued by boat. At that meeting, she shamed back. "I would respect more of you if you lived in our residences," she told the activists, her voice breaking. "I talk to my residents every day."
在一次会议上，他们让一位压力巨大的非洲裔住房管理者几乎流泪。他们指控她试图清理新奥尔良的非洲裔，指控她受贿、不关心。这是一位住在新奥尔良的女性，在被船只救出之前，曾在根蒂利的办公室屋顶上受困三天。在那次会议上，她反羞辱回去。“如果你们住在我们的住宅区，我会更尊重你们，”她告诉活动家，声音颤抖。“我每天都和我的居民交谈。”
The public housing shame wars also lead to bizarre moments of dueling activism, some hippie-on-hippie. The latest was a few days ago, when a bunch of bicycling and public park groovers made the mistake of saying it would be kind of neat to have a rails-to-trails type public bike path on a devastated and forgotten swath that cuts through the city, some of it near some projects. This prompted a different group of activists to accuse the bikers of colluding with HUD and the permanent expulsion of the community, which amounted to ethnic cleansing. Really, bike paths equal ethnic cleansing.
公共住房的羞耻战争还导致了荒谬的双重行动主义时刻，一些嬉皮士对抗嬉皮士。最近的一次是在几天前，当一群骑自行车和在公共公园玩耍的人犯了一个错误，说在城市中切开的一块被破坏和遗忘的带状区域——其中一些靠近一些项目——修一条铁路转步道式的公共自行车道会很不错。这引发了另一群活动家指控自行车手与HUD勾结，并永久驱逐社区，这相当于种族清洗。真的，自行车道等于种族清洗。
And then along comes Home Depot, who wants a piece of the C. J. Peete Housing Development real estate to build a store. And then there was the displaced granny in her wheelchair, and the mothers and the children threatening to break into their own homes, just to get their belongings, and hopefully clean out their apartments. Because HUD had locked them out with barbed wire, and in some places, steel doors, the spectacle of which should make us all really, truly ashamed.
然后家得宝来了，他们想要CJ皮特住房开发的一块房地产。还有坐在轮椅上的流离失所的老奶奶，以及威胁要闯入自己家门只是为了拿走财物，希望能清理公寓的母亲和孩子们。因为HUD已经用带刺铁丝网，在某些地方用钢门锁住了他们，这种景观真应该让我们所有人都感到真的、真正的羞耻。
A number of public housing residents simply want their old neighborhoods back, the good, the bad, and the ugly. But HUD claims mold and contamination make these properties uninhabitable. Some residents are quick to point out that HUD has a lot of nerve, given the conditions before the flood. "We've been living in mold. We've been living with backed-up sewage," one displaced resident of the Saint Bernard project rebuked to the local paper. "We've been living with gunshots over our heads and broken everything. Now all of a sudden, it's a hazard? It's been a hazard. But we want to come home."
许多公共住房居民只是想要回他们原来的街区，好的、坏的、丑的，都要。但HUD声称霉菌和污染使这些房产无法居住。一些居民很快指出，考虑到洪水前的条件，HUD真是胆大包天。“我们一直生活在霉菌中。我们一直生活在倒灌的污水中，”一位被拆迁的圣伯纳德项目居民向当地报纸责备道。“我们一直头顶枪声，一切都是坏的。现在突然间，它成了危害？它一直是个危害。但我们要回家。”
Last week, when I went to the Saint Bernard Housing Project the city has slated for demolition, tall chain link fences and barbed wire surrounded the blocks of deserted apartments. Earlier this month, I went to a meeting that the paper had billed as a place where people would discuss public housing issues. But no one from public housing was there.
上周，当我去了城市列入拆除名单的圣伯纳德住房项目时，高大的铁丝网栅栏和带刺铁丝网环绕着这些荒废的公寓街区。本月早些时候，我参加了一个报纸宣传为讨论公共住房问题的地方的会议。但没有一个来自公共住房的人在那里。
The man in charge said the paper had it all wrong. They were just looking for volunteers. He pointed to a small boom box and some women sitting at a fold-out table stacked with hot dog buns. "Today we're gutting houses and having a little DJ barbecue after," he said. He told me how he had been gutting and coordinating gutting for elderly and low-income displaced families for nearly a year.
负责人说报纸弄错了。他们只是在寻找志愿者。他指着一个小的动臂盒和一些坐在折叠桌旁的妇女，桌子上堆满了热狗面包。“今天我们正在清空房子，之后还要举行小型DJ烧烤，”他说。他告诉我，他几乎一年来一直在为老年和低收入流离失所家庭清空房子和协调清空工作。
I attempted to commiserate, telling him about all the houses that hadn't been gutted in our neighborhood, and how I and others were taking care of many of our elderly and displaced neighbors' yards. "But that's to keep up your own property," he said. "That's people helping themselves when they do that." I had the distinct feeling that he wanted me to put down my pen and pick up a claw hammer and help them gut some houses. I probably should have, but I didn't. I left ashamed.
我试图表示同情，告诉他我们邻里还有许多没有清空的房子，以及我和其他人如何照顾许多老年和流离失所邻居的院子。“但这只是为了保持你自己的房产，”他说。“那是人们在做这件事时帮助自己。”我有种明显的感觉，他希望我放下笔，拿起爪锤，帮他们清空一些房子。我大概应该这么做，但我没有。我带着羞耻离开了。
I predict that if things keep going the way they are, soon everyone in New Orleans with half a heart will be ashamed of themselves full time. I'm already ashamed of my boyfriend, who used his emergency disaster food stamps to buy tuna steaks and goat cheese. I'm ashamed of myself for sharing this meal.
我预测如果事情继续这样下去，很快新奥尔良每个有一半心灵的人都会全职为自己感到羞耻。我已经为我男朋友感到羞耻，他用他的紧急灾难食品券买了金枪鱼排和山羊奶酪。我为自己分享这顿饭感到羞耻。
I'm also ashamed of myself for writing this, instead of gutting an elderly person's house, and for having my 67-year-old mother help me carry rubble buckets from my own house gutting, even though she has both carpal tunnel and trigger finger. I feel bad for not going to Mass for the past 10 years, and for not washing my dogS this week. Does that help?
我也为自己写下这些而不是去清空老人的房子，以及让67岁的母亲帮我从我自己的房子清空工程中搬运碎石桶而感到羞耻，尽管她有腕管综合症和扳机指。我为过去10年没去做弥撒，以及这周没给我狗洗澡感到难过。这有帮助吗？
Cheryl Wagner in New Orleans.
新奥尔良的谢丽尔·瓦格纳。
Our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Steven January.
我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特管理我们的网站。制作帮助来自塞斯·林德和史蒂文·贾努阿里。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Covers of the song "The Cat Came Back" today were performed for us by Nedelle Torrisi, the band Headache City, and Mike Treese and DJ Rude One.
今天歌曲《猫又回来了》的翻唱版由Nedelle Torrisi、头痛城市乐队以及迈克·特里斯和DJ Rude One为我们表演。
(SUBJECT) NEDELLE TORRISI [SINGING] So I gave him to a scientist destined for the moon. The cat was used for ballast in an outer space balloon.
（主题）NEDELLE TORRISI [演唱] 所以我把他给了去月球的科学家。那只猫在外太空气球里被当作压舱物。
You know, you can download today's program at our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道，你可以从我们的audible.com/thisamericanlife档案中下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program, Mr. Torey Malatia, who has heard what we say about him at the end of every single show. And he has talked to a special public relations consultant, who helped him put together, finally, after all these years, a response. Here it is.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他听过我们每一期节目结尾对他说的评价。他已经和一位特别的公共关系顾问谈过，那位顾问帮助他最终，在这么多年之后，准备了一个回应。在这里。
Stop it, you buttheads.
停下，你们这些混蛋。
Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。